enfin nous avons françoise kramer vous
l'annonçait dans les titres de la
mi-journée à 13h01 nous avons sur notre
plateau une invité les lâches chalabi
c'est une jeune élève d'un lycée de
meaux pourquoi est-elle présente sur ce
plateau françoise pourquoi elle va nous
l'expliqué elle-même mais pour la
présenter rapidement je vous dirais
qu'il s'agit d'une jeune fille
algérienne de 20 ans qu'elle vivait
jusqu'à présent amour que vous êtes le
dire elle était élève d'un lycée
professionnel elle préparait un bts de
secrétariat de direction et c'est le
jour de ses 20 ans précisément le 26
avril qu'elle a commencé à avoir des
problèmes avec sa famille son père et
ses frères qui ne voulaient pas qu'elle
les valeurs européennes sont venus la
chercher et l'ont quasiment kidnappé
avant de la retenir de force à mulhouse
d'où elle vient de s'échapper avec des
amis pour demander la protection de la
police on la suit les détails on va
aller demander à aller là au départ tout
allait bien les là vous étiez une bonne
élève une jeune fille sage qu'est ce qui
s'est passé comment est ce que tout ça a
commencé bah il s'est passé que j'ai mis
en application tous les projets que je
faisais depuis l'âge de 15 ans c'est à
dire avoir une vie indépendante
j'ai donc cherché du travail j'ai
cherché une chambre etc et ça tout ça ça
allait à l'encontre de tout ce que mc
hulk et mes parents donc que les
problèmes qui s'ensuivent alors
voulez-vous renvoyé en algérie et vous
ne voulez pas vivre à l'algérie elle
voulait vivre à l'européenne voilà c'est
ça mais la menace de l'algérie
je ne sais pas s'ils l'auraient s'il
leur est appliqué françoise et les là si
vous permettez je t on tout de suite
pour vous signez
pourquoi ne vous voyons pas nous voyons
vos mains mademoiselle nous voyons votre
dos en ce moment aux cheveux et nous ne
verrons pas votre visage alors vous
chercher à éviter quelque chose à vous
protéger c'est à dire que premièrement
je pas qu'on retrouve et secundo les
gens qui sont dans la rue je veux pas
qu'ils reconnaissent et qu'on montre du
doigt cependant vous avez accepté de
venir parler avec nous au cours de ce
journal alors pourquoi est ce que vous
considérez que votre cause personnelle
c'est aussi la cause de beaucoup de
jeunes femmes de votre génération ça
parce que on m'a dit que j'étais un peu
un symbole bon j'en suis
j'en suis un peu fier mais je pense que
ça peut aider pas mal de jeunes
algériennes qui ont ce problème est
qu'ils n'ont pas le courage de faire ce
que j'ai fait et donc d'après mon
témoignage je pense que je serai je leur
serai utile le problème il est clair
c'est que vous ne voulez pas vivre comme
vous le demande certainement de votre
famille vous voulez vivre entre
guillemets bien sûr l'européenne c'est
bien cela c'est ça mais il ya quelque
chose que j'aurais précisé c'est à dire
que je ne renie pas ma culture je veux
vivre à l'européenne mais en gardant des
mii racines algériennes mes racines
musulmanes avec des coutumes que
j'accepte et d'autres que je n'accepte
pas on a voulu quand même vous empêcher
de vivre cette façon et c'est ce qui
vous a motivé à fuir aujourd'hui vous
êtes protégé par des amis par des jeunes
femmes qui partagent notre cause oui
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'il ya des
associations qui qui me protège et qui
m'aident matériellement des associations
féministes et ce qui était intéressant
c'est que il y a également des
associations de jeunes algériens et des
algériennes qui sont solidaires avec moi
ils vous intéressera peut-être en
moselle de savoir que nous avons appelé
tout à l'heure l'ambassade d'algérie
pour parler de votre cas pour
l'ambassade d'algérie s'agit pas du tout
d'un conflit politique il s'agit d'un
conflit familial
premièrement et deuxièmement l'ambassade
considère que vous n'avez rien à
craindre de la communauté algérienne et
que même la limite ou pourriez très bien
montré votre visage enfin les gens à
l'ambassade que nous avons appelée
précise que des beaucoup de jeunes
femmes jeunes filles de ce qu'on appelle
la deuxième génération ont le même
problème que vous quel commentaire
faites-vous assez
marc c'est à dire que je pense que
l'ambassade d'algérie peut avoir le
moins de soucis possible et ne veut pas
entendre parler des c'est à dire qu'elle
veut pas avoir une position dans cette
affaire je pense qu'elle va essayer de
rester neutre et elle essaie de défendre
encore ses droits mais quel genre de 2,2
d'avenir de vie envisagez vous vous
n'allez pas vivre dissimuler toute votre
vie ça non je vais reprendre mes études
parce que mes parents toujours espérer
que que je devienne quelqu'un plus tard
donc je vais reprendre mes études à
l'étranger et puis plus tard je
reviendrai et je reprendrai des contacts
avec mes parents
michel jonasz ou suez se veut mais je
trouve que c'est très bien
et c'est vrai qu'elle l'a dit elle même
que c'est un symbole c'est vrai que si
débat rançons sont preuve d'intolérance
comme ça avec leur propre fille comment
voulez vous que des peuples entre eux
proposent un tel de tolérance pour ceux
qui se battent
d'avoir supporté cette existence quasi
clandestine pendant longtemps les lun
vous n'avez pas envie tout de même
d'avoir rapport avec votre famille et
vos parents non je n'ai pas envie
d'avoir des rapports pour le moment mais
j'espère que je ne resterai pas dans la
clandestinité longtemps parce que c'est
très difficile mais que votre mère n'y a
pas de négociation de discussion
possible donc c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'on imagine bien la faire c'est à dire
que ça fait des années pourront qu'on
essaye de discuter là dessus des années
que je présente les choses qu'on a
toujours refusé bon un moment il faut
passer à l'action et pas autre chose à
faire mais quand vous présentez les
choses c'est à dire vous un jour vous
avez une barre à 6,02 retenait rouler à
l'e10 voilà moi je ne veux pas vivre
comme cela
là c'est un refus et puis des menaces et
pas plus
merci les là d'avoir bien voulu venir
nous parler de votre cas et nous
tournons